you're like becoming the Taylor Swift
for the Eagles because when you're there
at the game they're cutting to you in
the owner's box the entire game like how
does that happen does the owner get in
touch with you and he goes so when I did
Silver Linings Playbook you know back in
2010 the Eagles you know opened up their
Enterprise to us to a large degree and
then I became friends with um uh Jeff
Lori and then Andy Reed was the coach at
the time and he was so friendly to me I
remember yeah and then I'm just lucky
enough to be able to um you go to a lot
of games and been able to bring my
daughter and my mom and uh friends and
it's been it's it's it's been amazing to
watch my daughter she now actually is
able to tell when we're on defense and
offense and she's like go D go D do you
get uptight saying to them hey I want to
come to the game I mean because you know
you don't want to be a schneur you don't
want to take advantage of their
generosity so you got to like time right
you can't go to every
game okay I'm glad you're telling me
that okay oh you didn't
know you've been going every game
okay here's the big question and I
really want you to answer this in a
serious manner okay Sophie's choice for
2024 you win the Oscar not only for best
director but best actor and Carrie
Mulligan wins best actress or the Eagles
have a Super Bowl victory what Super
Bowl victory eag wow Eagles I know
you're lying now aren't you I don't
think so bro no no the Eagles I'm not
lying I'm you know you live New York now
right